I am thrilled we have a great show for
you tonight ah ha ha good one coming
[Applause]
good to see you jack
take I'm curious what did you mean by
haha good one
I just figured you were making one of
your world-famous goofs before you
surprised us with a holiday visit from
you-know-who wink wink wink one hates
top wink we're gonna wink wink don't not
wink and then say Wayne what do you mean
by you know who I'm talking about our
old pal
minty Jack's talking about one of our
show's characters from the past
minty the candy cane who briefly fell on
the ground yeah there yet yeah where's
that old rascal hiding come on okay all
right I knew we'd have to have this talk
one day Jack I'm afraid minty
isn't coming back ever again don't say
that sorry jack I loved minty just as
much as you did maybe even more you shut
that bus station toilet you call a mouth
mister
no one loves me more than me
where is minty Conan please tell me
minty is someplace better now he's in
heaven
no he's in New York City you see minty
was played by one of our former writers
Brian McCann yeah Brian McCann played
minty and Brian moved to New York a few
years ago so we had to retire the
character minty forever
about the holidays won't be the same
without my pal I'm sorry I'm really I'm
sorry it but it would take some kind of
miracle to bring back minty and you
don't have miracles at Christmas it
[Applause]
might have been my new marching boots
and he just wears those sleigh bell buoy
this time of year don't let that fool
you yeah like I said Jack and you don't
the march in place anymore Andy there is
no way that Minty's ever coming back no
way
[Applause]
Brian McCann came all the way from New
York at the Holiday America yes it's
crazy
minty how did you get here I did I had a
bunch of frequent flyer mine
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so tonight from the new movie rogue one
a Star Wars toy diego luna's
[Applause]
that's gonna cut people in the true TV
series Billy on the street
Billy Eichner
[Applause]
here's against pretenders
[Applause]
[Music]
you